what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so while this technically takes place
before the events of Dark Knight's medal
in terms of chronology I consider it to
be a time and the reason why is because
this deals with the whole idea of in
metal in terms of what is capable what
it can do and why it's so powerful in
the realm of DC Comics remember when it
came to Dark Knights metal that
basically amplified a really sort of
expanded on the nature of infidel prior
to Dark Knights metal and metal with
just this this material that existed out
there but there wasn't really anything
special about it had magical properties
and that was really about it what Dark
Knight's metal does is it basically says
that metal is permeated throughout the
entirety of the DC Multiverse
but it all originates from the Dark
multiverse and so it's cool because what
this also does is it sees the return of
one of the most powerful villains that
existed out there in the realm of DC
Comics now initially we basically just
pick up with these beings that look very
similar to Celestials from Marvel Comics
in terms of the physical form in the
middle of all this while the Green
Lantern's are sort of wrestling with a
fallout of the whole fractured story arc
which basically saw the alliance between
the Green Lantern's and the Sinestro
Corps coming to an end some members of
the Sinestro Corps staying with the
Green Lantern's but a good portion of
them basically leaving and taking off
into space what this means is the Green
Lantern's numbers are basically down to
almost zero again keep in mind that when
most of the Green Lantern's were kind of
shunted off to the beginning of all
things to the beginning of time more or
less in the universe what it did is it
allowed the Sinestro Corps to sort of
rise to prominence as a police force but
where Thal Sinestro himself was
eventually defeated and believed to have
been killed the result is that his
daughter cirrhotic took over the
Sinestro Corps as a former Green Lantern
now where her father was very villainous
in terms of how he ran the whole
Sinestro Corps she ran it is more of a
superhero kind of team and forming an
alliance with the Green Lantern's when
that ended it was all predicated on the
idea that the child of Kyle Rayner the
Green Lantern and cirrhotic not two came
from the future that child was killed
and then Kyle Rayner didn't tell Sonic
what happened and the result is that she
lost all trust in the Green Lantern and
sort of became a villain to Syd neo
declared herself the new Sinestro and
took off into space you know we covered
that with the whole lot the whole
fractured storyline but the long and
short of this is that the Green
Lantern's numbers are still very very
thin and so is really left to Jon
Stewart as a leader of the Green Lantern
Corps to try to hold it all together
it's always really doing double duty in
a lot of different ways on one side he's
going through and he's trying to make
sure that what's left of the Green
Lantern's still maintain themselves as a
Co
piece of team which by and large they're
doing for the most part the other half
of this is that the universe still needs
to be protected there's still villains
out there there's still things that the
Green Lantern's have to do and they're
trying to maintain that role but in the
midst of this huge you know spark of
energy that's more or less picked up by
Jon Stewart of course he sends Kyle
Rayner and he sends a Hal Jordan to
investigate the problem is when they get
there what they end up finding is an
entire star system has been totally
obliterated when this happens of course
what we end up having are boom tubes
that are opening what immediately
follows is not just the character of
Orion but Omega beams and Omega beams
are usually a direct indication of the
presence of Darkseid now one of the
things I want to talk about here is the
character of Orion because we've talked
about them before but for a lot of
people who are jumping into DC rebirth
Orion is a foreign concept to them they
don't really know anything about him so
when it comes to the new god you've
basically got apocalypse with Darkseid
and you've got new Genesis with
highfather and the new 52 they're
basically brothers but the whole idea
here is that they represent the very
nature of the opposing dichotomies of
good and evil that's really what they
are
apocalypse is evil new Genesis is good
now in a lot of ways their motivations
can be called into question there are
times where you know the good guys New
Genesis guys have done some pretty
questionable things but overall despite
what they might do in the short term in
the long term they're good guys they're
heroes and they function that way now
with the whole idea of these two
opposing forces inevitably they went to
war with one another and they Ward for
like eons and eons and eons in order to
basically construct a truce what ended
up happening is one of the beings that
was part of the whole new gods mythos
called met Ron had basically brokered a
truce between the two worlds what they
would do is they would exchange their
sons and so what ended up happening is a
Ryan the son of Darkseid was sent to
live with highfather whereas the son of
high father Scott free was sent to live
with Darkseid that's the reason why
Scott free mister miracle is kind of
like a master escape artist because the
locks were so strong and so durable on
apocalypse that him being able to
basically break out of those made him
capable of breaking through some of the
the best you know devices that exists
out there in terms of blocks and codes
and different things like that but Orion
being a member of the New Gods has
always been more or less the Prince of
New Genesis which is to say he adopted
son more or less of high father and the
role he plays has always been the sort
of on-again off-again hero that's worked
alongside the various superheroes now
the reason why I say on-again off-again
is just because of the fact
remember for years and years and years
the new gods are basically isolated to
their own line of comets so you didn't
see them cross over all the time but it
was usually always Orion who is like the
liaison when it came to the new gods
working alongside superheroes but
there's history here is really kind of
the overall point that Robert Venditti
is making here it's not like the new
gods are meeting the Green Lantern's for
the very first time not only that the
last time these two groups met Kyle
Rayner was the white Lantern he was the
most powerful of all the lanterns who
were out there the funny thing about
this though is that when a Ryan shows up
he's like look you know there's
something hunting us in New Genesis
trying to kill off all the New Gods uh
we need y'all's help and we really
really need the white lantern like if
you guys know if the white lanterns here
get him because like we could really use
his help we really need the white
lantern and it's funny because kyle
rayner used to be the white lantern and
he's not anymore so it's kind of
interesting and of course this basically
falls in the shoulders of just the Green
Lantern's to cope with on their own but
keep in mind when it comes to the new
gods they are in a lot of ways almost
immutable and indestructible I mean they
can be killed but it takes beings of
immense power in order to pull it off
and so when the new gods show up and
they're like we need we you know we
basically need help and these times are
that dire because under normal
circumstances Green Lantern's should not
be able to take on and defeat beings
that are capable of overpowering new
gods the problem is that things are just
that bad now of course with these Omega
beams basically hitting Orion these
Omega beams function in the exact same
capacity that we're used to once their
sicked on the target they find that
target and they keep chasing after them
until they hit them or until that target
goes to a place but the Omega beams
can't follow on the surface this looks
like dark side it looks like dark side
is somehow a reappeared dark sides back
and waging a war against the new gods
the problem with this is that once they
basically get you know a Ryan onto a
stretcher when they get him back ah what
is up happening is his heart is more or
less shut down when his heart is
restarted when he's brought back he
immediately panics because he's like all
hope is lost here this planet is going
to be obliterated because the Omega
beams are going to continue following
him until they're dead and again the
reason for this is because Orion is
basically being chased by a giant
machine of source basically one of these
Celestials and the cynthia's Omega beams
after him and that once it believed that
he was dead when his heart stopped it
backed off but when he was brought back
and immediately started chasing after
him again so this thing appears to have
been designed if
the purpose of just tracking down and
killing new gods everywhere it can find
them but notice this this thing is
wildly powerful I mean it's huge it's
monstrous in size it's very much like a
celestial from Marvel Comics and it's
really intriguing whether the Green
Lantern's face off against it as best
they can evacuating people out where
they can what we end up having is the
head of the medical staff that was able
to save save Orion has effectively
created a fake heart of sorts it's
really this idea that this heart can be
used to basically continue circulating
blood throughout the body of Orion while
his physical heart is stopped and so
what ends up happening here is once they
pull this off once Kyle Rayner creates
this construct and is basically able to
use it to artificially continue pumping
blood throughout the body of Orion
because it's physically his physical
heart is believed to have stopped this
thing immediately backs off and it moves
on to its next target so again
constantly going after all these
different new gods tracking these guys
down taking these guys out this is a
pretty overwhelming force now following
this once we get him back to the Green
Lantern base of operations that's when
the information begins to come in
remember when it comes to Robert
Venditti who's you know writing style
he's from what I've been able to see a
lot of this kind of an introductory
thing you know things going crazy things
going nuts and then we start to get into
the explanation it's designed to grab us
and realest in these massive machines
are basically being referred to as
golems but the reason why I consider
this to be a Dark Knight's metal tie-in
is because what it does is it picks up
on two things the first is the nature of
in metal in terms of the fact that it's
one of the most powerful concepts that
exists out there but the second is also
the character of yuga Khan now you get
Khan as meant most people probably don't
know is the father of Darkseid but the
way it's history is done here is a
little bit intriguing when it came to
the new 52 and the origin of Darkseid
himself Yuga Khan didn't really exist he
wasn't really their dark side as you
class you know basically led a rebellion
against the old gods took them all out
and then him and highfather went to war
against each other and that was the end
of that Yuga Khan is largely a pre new
52 character meaning a character who
largely had a book of his appearances
before 2011 now even before then he goes
all the way back to the 1970s well
you're talking about a guy who's
appeared in DC Comics less than like a
hundred and fifty times he hasn't shown
up all that often but the mega nations
and the schemes of yuga khan are for the
most part always the same he was the
original god among all gods the most
powerful of all gods in existence he ran
apocalypse with an eye
fists he was hardcore he was ruthless
and he was cutthroat but he desired to
attain absolute power and tried to enter
the source basically the source of all
energy of all beings that exists in the
DC Universe the result is that once he
tried to pass through the source wall
like all other beings who have tried to
enter the source he was locked inside
the wall and he was presumably stuck
there for all eternity what this does is
it expands on that initial origin and it
basically says that what you kakan also
had was basically an army of sorts that
was composed almost entirely of metal
and the reason why this matters is
because no one believed this army was
real a lot of that was because when it
came to Yuga Khan because him being
locked in the source wall that happened
so long before the events of a lot of
the modern-day stories had taken place
the result is that he was largely
believed to have just been a myth but
with the idea that Yuga Khan had
basically been locked away in a source
wall and was essentially trying to
engineer his own escape these machines
effectively reactivated this army came
to fruition again with two main purposes
the first was to follow the campaign
follow the programming instituted by
Yuga Khan to eliminate all individuals
who that possibly take over as the ruler
of Apocalypse and his absence
effectively eliminating heirs the second
of this was to bring yuga Khan back now
remember right now when it comes to DC
rebirth Darkseid is not Darkseid anymore
he's not there anymore he's basically
just a baby
he doesn't really pose a challenge in
terms of people who are capable of being
able to take over the throne of
apocalypse in the absence of yoga Khan
then it means Oh Ryan is the most
logical person to do it because a Ryan
is the biological son of Darkseid so a
lot of history that's thrown in a lot of
the backlog of stories that have taken
place but following this what they end
up doing is they basically say okay we
have to search his mind even further
because we have to find out where hi
father is hi father being a leader of
all the new gods in New Genesis is
largely believed to be one of the more
powerful of the new gods right up there
with the power of Darkseid and so if the
Green Lantern's are struggling against
these golems then of course highfather
is perceived to be their best measure of
being able to take these guys out
simultaneously if they are hunting new
gods then it stands to reason they're
hunting high father and so because of
this once they track down where it is
that high father may be at the only
thing they're able to gain is the name
of a person called light ray now light
ray is like the New Gods version of the
flash and his character is actually
pretty intriguing he made us
first appearance in New Gods number one
back in 1971 but like a lot of the other
New Gods he was given a pretty cool
origin in the sense that him and Orion
were extremely close friends the issue
here is that somewhere along the line
light ray and Orion who basically
discovered like an apocalyptic outpost
or something like that there was on new
Genesis and the result was that
following a battle my way was hit with
like a whole bunch of solar radiation he
fell into a coma for a while and when he
popped back up he had all these solar
powers he could basically manipulate
light itself in a multitude of different
ways now one of the things that he did
is he actually ended up pushing himself
and kind of becoming the fastest of all
the new gods so in a lot of ways light
Ray was like Marvel's Macari that was an
eternal who basically devoted all of his
power to pushing his speed to the
absolute limits with light ray it's much
the same way but because of this with
white ray being the fastest of all the
new gods he's basically able to traverse
all through space and time uh using you
know his power of flight but with Hal
Jordan basically tasked with trying to
track down light ray and ultimately
locate whether or not he actually has
highfather with him the biggest
hindrance he has is as constructs do not
seem to be able to move as fast as light
rays able to travel now of course this
is actually a pretty amazing moment here
because while he's trying to pilot this
ship
he basically ends up backing the whole
thing down he really just kind of slows
down and it seems like all hope is lost
when he's basically met with an image of
his father now we're not told how he got
here it's basically this whole idea that
his dad appears and offers these words
of encouragement to Hal Jordan I have
faith in you I believe in you but it's a
very touching moment because one of the
things that's really always emphasized
when it comes to the character of how as
his father always played an exceedingly
large role in his life albeit the fact
that his father had died when he was
younger the results of this is that
every time how Jordan flies whenever it
is and he goes on some mission or
something like that he needs to kind of
pep himself up prepare for what it is
it's gonna happen his question is what
would my dad do what would my father do
in this situation and again it's a
really beautiful and touching aspect of
his character because of course were the
questions asked am i hallucinating you
you know what in the world is going on
here instead of his father sort of being
just this kind of general image he
speaks and moves as if you were actually
there in real life and even goes as far
as to say I don't really know if you're
hallucinating me or not you're basically
in the wake of a cosmic God is flying at
the speed of light it's very ambiguous
it's very cloak-and-dagger but it's not
designed to
answer the question is his father really
here it's designed to emphasize the
nature and the relationship between Hal
Jordan and his dad and how big of a role
his father plays and so again because of
the fact that his dad was courageous
because of the fact that his dad did
whatever it took in order to achieve the
goal Hal Jordan follows the exact same
path and where he begins flying his ship
pulling up on the speed of light what we
also end up having is this warning
coming from his construct that Hal
Jordan is approaching a speed force
singularity what this means is that if
he kept traveling faster he would have
entered the speed force mode most likely
Hal Jordan may have gained the powers of
the flash it's cool with him basically
running into highfather running into
light ray he basically says look I can
take over from here if you guys need me
to I can help out and it makes sense
because hi father's response is despite
the powers of light ray while he is a
new God his energy is not infinite
eventually he'll tire out and with those
Omega beams chasing them down as he
begins to slow the beams do not slow
down with Hal Jordan grabbing highfather
bringing him on board and basically
taking off between the two of them it's
interesting because these Omega beams
are still following them and if that
caldron actually comes up with this
pretty ingenious plan where the
constructive Kyle Rayner is being used
continually to basically maintain the
constructive serving as the heart of
Orion he's not really able to leave and
not really able to go anywhere instead
what we end up finding out is that
because of the fact that these are mega
beams are chasing after the new gods or
at least you know only those who are
present in this immediate vicinity
chasing after high father and because of
the fact a Ryan is believed to have been
dead these golems move on to their
second process which is trying to free
either Kahn from the source wall now
keep in mind if you kakan is freed if
this happens then all hope is lost
basically everybody's gonna die the
other question has to be asked here is
how does this coincide with the Dark
Side war Shazam one shot those are guys
who don't know Billy Batson also known
as Shazam really Captain Marvel back in
the 1930s derived his powers from a
handful of different gods you know all
of whom basically spelled out the
acronym Shazam the issue is that during
the original Darkseid war storyline at
the tail end of the new 52
Shazam got his powers from a new set of
gods one of which was yuga Khan the last
we saw him he was just kind of preparing
to institute his campaign so we don't
really know how to bridge this gap
between the last time we saw you the con
and how
ended up in the source wall I don't
really believe is a continuity error
just because BC rebirth plays continuity
pretty close to the best it may be that
kind of thing gets fleshed out later on
down the line most likely when it comes
to the return of Shazam himself whether
it's in a solo series or what-have-you
or if you get conned manages to be freed
from the source wall and then gives us
this whole great big huge exposition on
what it wasn't happened with his
character and how he got to where he is
you know when DC gives us a whole
backstory but it's cool because remember
if you've akan gets out everybody dies
and so that's the first instance of the
of the Green Lantern's is to fight this
war on two fronts the first part is to
stop all these different guns and the
second is to keep them away from yuga
khan so it's a pretty desperate scenario
now of course with regards to Hal Jordan
and highfather
essentially racing back with the Omega
beams following them they basically play
chicken and it's a pretty genius
maneuver here in the sense that Hal
Jordan effectively dies out of the way
just before the moment of impact and the
Omega beams hit one of the golems and
completely incinerate them funneling
that it's a matter of trying to take out
as many other of these beans as they
can't once they learn the weakness is
basically the the point in their chest
then it becomes a matter of just
creating as many constructs as they can
as large as they can and just hammering
it away at all until they can finally
take these guys out with all these
different golems having been defeated
the final one appears and so of course
highfather kind of jumps into the fray
and highfather is able to crack the
armor just enough for jon stewart to
fire off a killing shot and to destroy
this thing but keep in mind hi father
while he is powerful is not all-powerful
he can be destroyed but the fact that
these things were designed for the
purpose of destroying new gods meant
that they had to have been designed for
the purpose of destroying new gods of
all power like highfather otherwise
there'd be no purpose in creating that
army and so as a result with the final
golem having been destroyed basically
haven't been taken out that impetus
basically falls on highfather
to sort of you know taunt you become
little bit say hey there's no chance of
you getting out and really sort of
calling it a day
and so the story basically wraps up this
quick little involvement with the new
gods and the Green Lantern's themselves
sort of teaming up these kind of wrap up
with a Ryan having his heart put back
into his chest
everybody's saying peace you know thanks
for helping out and they go their own
separate ways things wrap up pretty fast
it's not really one of these stories
that was designed to set the stage for
everything else that goes on and all
these expansive things and all that kind
of good stuff
again it's just one of these stories
it's designed to remind us characters
like utak on still exist there are some
pretty formidable threat
they're the source wall all those things
are still out there so it is pretty cool
and it certainly is interesting in terms
of what may come after this but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explained make sure you
guys to the sub button to become part of
the rod cork if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]